another thing I want to ask you there
are things about me that you don't like
because you brought it up in the last
year come there are so let's just you
know what I think this is a good time
period right price in there for what do
you like God there was a [ __ ] TV back
arts heathen laughs yeah you sleep
alright I think this is a good time baby
get it out you get it off our chest why
not go ahead okay
what is it I do hope you're open first
of all you don't first there's a few
things you don't text back that's not
okay dude look at him everyone here is
not and I know what text back way text
back right text back okay go ahead what
are you gonna do with this by the way
whenever I need I have a rebuttals okay
you don't text back okay when we go to a
diner
yeah you just eat and then you're done
and you leave and I don't like okay it's
for hanging out and I'm go to a diner to
eat and that's not cool you go to a
diner to hang out with your friends
number number number three is [ __ ] what
was your name what what what is it that
when I see you in public I get the
Comedy Store so I don't get into
conversation yeah I know it yeah it's
fine that we don't get into a
conversation but you just you just you
don't sometimes you just walk by yeah
and you say hey to like some other
player like Emma Christie or whoever put
your friends with and I love Kevin
then you won't say hi to me okay good
don't say hi yeah well you think you
when we're at a diner sometimes you'll
you'll be like and you'll start playing
your games and and those are good for
there very good thing very good [ __ ]
rebuttal that's very I love you
we were talking about you I love you but
let me just can I please thank you okay
all right text back number one okay
communication with your phone right for
me is a lifeline to the world just
listen to what I'm saying I know you're
doing your eyes on their baggie right
now so it's I your taxes are like this
bra bra they're kind of like that spell
something yeah I do what you dealing
yeah right yeah yeah
oh that's [ __ ] you do right so I'm 45
yeah I'll be honest with you and I'm in
the car I get a text from Chris bra bra
I saw right I bend minutes no I so I
just kind of let it go yeah so if you
were to do something like hey dude I
went to the hospital and I got some bad
news right let me tell you something
right now no no Lisa fake crying okay no
something right now I'd be the first one
the text you back
I now dude let me ask you a question
yeah why why what why would you be the
first one because I love you so much I
think what it is yeah you secretly want
to get in good with God I think you want
points with whoever you use this [ __ ]
made me so angry right now made me so
[ __ ] angry that I am NOT even gonna
[ __ ] address it right now okay
alright yeah the second one is this I
eat and I'm done okay let me tell you
something right now friend all right all
right bro you're I don't you're pointing
at me let me tell you something about
you right now right okay all right let
me say something all right to survive in
life you need several things you need
oxygen
yeah right you need h2o when I got water
water right you need sleep shelter right
and [ __ ] food right so what I'm
saying to you right now is is that like
if you and I
like camping we're sleeping yeah and
when I'm done sleeping yeah I'm not
gonna just lay next to you all right
in the tent and just watch you [ __ ]
sleep right I'm gonna go out chop some
wood for us someone get some fire right
I'm gonna get the bow and arrows ready
so if I'm gonna get bow and arrows ready
for us for the great hunt right yeah
sure right and then like an hour later
you wake up and I already have coffee
ready for you dude
yeah but uh it's what I'm saying is is
that that's what eating to me is eating
is once I'm done eating I'm off he
doesn't know how to just hang out I know
it's a big that's the bigger thing then
last week we went to shabu shabu it and
you sit on those large it's almost like
a communal kind of area and it's just
him and I right halfway through the meal
I'm not done yet he's out smoking a
cigarette and then he pays and I'm still
eating there for the last 20 minutes by
myself it's just not you it's everybody
I know it's not just me but so what so
then what do you do when he's out there
in the beginning you used to really
preserve me I would imagine used to make
oh my god it used to really bother me
and at some point I realized it was
probably just as ATD taking over it is
and it wasn't anything I could take
personally I need help so I did that I
won the text me Bobby what Kris y10
Bobby you want to eat I'm done I won
that one
- camping analogy right yeah don't say
hi okay I got a great thing for the okay
this is it all right so you know usually
you and I will see each other primarily
in a social setting like a comedy club
right okay so here's a guy right he's a
good-looking male you know alpha male
stand-up who's successful did two shows
back to back on a network right he's you
know he's like I'm you know he's the
light and that there's malls around him
oh okay all right so I pull up right I
got nothing Mike Mike my light is dim
that's stupid I know
talk alright everyone so walk it like
one Marco is that a lot yeah yeah
then I see a brighter light right Daigo
I no more [ __ ] mouth bro right I'm a
light too right do you hear what I'm
saying so it's like when a dimmer light
goes into a brighter light when he has
all those mouths sometimes the dimmer
light will just walk on by yeah and
doesn't say hello
alright cuz they're like yeah what cuz
her lights
no he's just saying you shut the [ __ ] up
right now I love you but yeah that's why
I understand but but you're but you're
you're you're bigger than that you know
what I mean
no yeah you are because you'll say hi
you'll say hi to other people right and
then you won't say hi to me you say hi
to the matching lights people who are in
the same baby Tim I couldn't set a
better but yeah but that's the thing
though yeah that's the [ __ ] 25
percent disrespect is what I'm talking
about
what who think I need that you think I
need someone you think you can walk on
by yeah I don't need that [ __ ] will you
need more moths no no no you you are who
you are in your head bro not on the
outside man I am Who I am in my head do
it
when you walk by you don't say [ __ ] yeah
I'm inside my head bro yeah how do you
think I get facebook eyes right now
right now that one a draw
you know what it's a draw it's only to
zero okay that was a good point
all right you two one
he wanted that one alright I'll give you
maybe one the camping analogy one but
not the texting one do it alright I
think it's hot it's 2 2 1 1
I'll keep it won't walk alright games ok
Oh games won't we're eating yeah okay
here's the feel all right yeah
when you're at a diner with this [ __ ]
guy you usually we go out with what you
Fahim yes maybe some other people you
know will sasso right right sure you
have all these funny guys right at a
table right and what happens with these
guys that they riff yeah and they try to
outdo each other and they try to build
this like fun cake try build a fun cake
right big one right and you know what I
do I'm done I'm done baking fun cakes
yeah you don't really big I'm thinking
about it right now yeah yeah I actually
am and that's really interesting
yeah cuz you're the kind of guy you got
all the things you got all the [ __ ]
tools to build the fun cake yeah you
know I have all the ingredients you know
I have the apron I have the oven I have
all the ingredients on you you have it
all right you know what you are
well you're the red belt on [ __ ] fun
cake you got your the you're the black
belt with all the red stripes tied all
around cuz you're [ __ ] first down
second on third all the done and the
whole belt is covered in red yeah you
just sit back and you watch everyone
else fight that's what you do yeah I
know and you know what what why is that
a bad thing because sometimes yeah we
want the sensei or the red belt to just
kind of assimilate with us and I think I
won that you 1 K 2 1 you definitely won
that one
ok ok well that's it though but I gave
you a really big compliment the end I
think that's why you let me win that
you're saying okay you won that one yeah
call you red belt at the end of the day
with the truth is this is that I know I
won 3-0 that's the truth okay and I'm
just letting you have it my guest
let me tell you something well I haven't
been in a room this small with this many
people since I was in high school yeah
there's so many [ __ ] people I hope
that in the cameras don't see I know
right yeah and I'm sorry but you know
when we as this thing grows yeah
you know that we get guests like
yourself and it's gonna get bigger and
then we'll have to we'll be forced to
move okay well I hope I can help that
you know you're gonna help that and and
we want to help you because you have a
podcast I do thank you yeah yeah I have
AB yeah yeah it's called
relations I want to plug that all right
so it's called congratulations as Chris
D'Elia
[Music]